اهلا بكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره
تتجه تركيا فيما يبدو نحو جوله اعاده
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في 28 من مايو بعد ان
تراجعت نسبه الاصوات التي حصل عليها
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وقد فاتت
وسائل الاعلام الرسميه بتقدمه في وقت مبكر
مساء الاحد الا انه اخفق في تحقيق
الاغلبيه اللازمه لاعلان فوزه في الجوله
الاولى
وتمديد حكمه البالغ 20 عاما نسبه تقدم
اردوغان تراجعت الى اقل من 50% من الاصوات
بعد فرز اكثر من 98% بحسب وكاله انباء
الاناضول الحكوميه
واذا كانت الحال كذلك ستكون سابقه في
تاريخ الجمهوريه التركيه الحديثه للفوز في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه يجب ان يحصل احد
المرشحين الرئيسيين على اغلبيه 50% من
الاصوات زائد واحد وهو ما لم يتحقق حتى
الان لاي من المرشحين بعد فرز اكثر من 98%
من الاصوات
مرشح تحالف المعارضه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه
اعلن ان النسبه الخياليه التي اظهرت بدايه
فرج الاصوات تقدم اردوغان بنسبه 60%
تراجعت الان الى خمسين بالمئه كانت جدار
دعا في تغريده على حساب الرسمي مراقبي
الانتخابات الى عدم تركيب مقاعدهم ودع
لجنه الانتخابات الوطنيه الى اعلان
البيانات القادمه من جميع الولايات
وقال كلتش انه سيقبل قرار الشعب للجوله
الثانيه مضيفا ان الرئيس اردوغان لم يحصل
على نتيجه التي يريدها في انتخابات الامس
على الرغم من كل حملاته التشريه والشتائم
لم يحصل اردوغان على النتيجه التي توقعها
لا ينبغي لاحد ان يتحمس لامر واقع لا يتم
الفوز بالانتخابات من على الشرفه ولا تزال
نتائج الانتخابات تتوالى اذا قررت امتنا
اجراء جوله الاعاده فعلى الرحب والسعه
سنفوز بالتاكيد في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات وسيرى الجميع ذلك
النتيجه تعلن في اقصر وقت ممكن لم يعد
بامكان هذا البلد ان يتسامح مع عدم اليقين
لا تخاف من اراده الشعب ادعو المجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات لاتحلى بالمسؤوليه لقد
وقعنا الوثائق لا تدعوا الجمهور يصرف
انتباهه اكرر لا تعطلوا ارادت هذه الامه
اناشد ايضا المتطوعين في مجال الديمقراطيه
الموجودين حاليا في الميدان الا يتركوا
صناديق الاقتراع والمجالس الانتخابيه ابدا
نحن هنا حتى يتم احتساب كل صوت شكرا
للصحفيين الاعزاء
الرئيس رجب في كلمه لها امام مناصره قال
انه متقدم في الانتخابات بفرق شاسع واصفا
منافسي بالمخادعين بقولهم انهم متقدمون في
النتائج
[موسيقى]
بلادنا في انتخابات 14 من مايو شهدت عرسا
ديمقراطيا نعم النتائج النهائيه لم تظهر
بعد لكننا متقدمون بفرق شاسع هم يعلمون
انهم كانوا يخدعون الناس بقولهم انهم
متقدمون في النتائج لكننا لسنا مثلهم نحن
صادقون ومخلصون النتائج النهائيه لم تظهر
بعد ونحن ننتظر اعلانها بشكل رسمي ومعلن
نحن ننتظر تجلى شرعيتنا في النتائج
النهائيه
جداول الانتخابات ستظهر الفائز بشكل واضح
لا يقبل الشك وبلادنا هي الفائزه في
الانتخابات مهما كانت النتيجه ان نسبه
المشاركه في هذه الانتخابات هي الاكبر في
تاريخنا السياسي نحن ننتظر من الجميع هذا
النضج الديمقراطي واتمنى ان تمر هذه
الانتخابات دون ان نشهد اي امر مؤسف
النقاشات التي كانت في مراحل الحملات
الانتخابيه باتت وراءنا وفي هذا الاطار
قال شعبنا كلمته ويجب احترام ذلك اننا
نتجاوز اقرب منافس لنا بمليونين و600 الف
صوت وانا واثق من ان الارقام في صناديق
الاقتراع ستزداد اكثر فاكثر نحن نؤمن
بقدرتنا على الفوز بالانتخابات من الجوله
الاولى واذا كان قرار الشعب اجراء جوله
ثانيه فذلك مرحب به
متابع التغطيه من انقره مع الدكتور باسل
الحاج جاسم الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور باسل هل هذه النتيجه كانت متوقعه
تقارب لهذه الدرجه ما بين كلتشدار
وبين الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وعدم الحصن
في الجوله الاولى من هذا الانتخابات
صباح الخير اخي محمد في الواقع الكثير من
استطلاعات الراي التي جرت في الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه على الرغم طبعا من عدم
دقه هذه الاستطلاعات الا ان الكثير منها
اشار الى تقارب في هذه النسب وايضا الكثير
منها اشاره الى امكانيه اللجوء الى جوله
ثانيه
دكتور باسل
مره اخرى مع الدكتور باسل الدكتور كنت
تتحدث عن ان هذه النتائج كانت متوقعه
الكثير من استطلاعات الراي اشارت الى
امكانيه اللجوء لجوله ثانيه مع عدم قدره
اي من المتنافسين على الحسم من الجوله
الاولى
ايضا من بين تعقيدات هذه الانتخابات لم
يكن هناك قدره على اعطاء توقع دقيق
وعدم معرفه انه من يمكنه حسمها مسبقا يعني
سابقا الكثير من الانتخابات التي جرت في
تركيا مسبقا كان معروف الحسم لاي جهه
وبنسب مريحه هذه الانتخابات معظم التوقعات
كانت تعطي في حال تمكن احد من الاطراف
الفوز وحسمها الا ان هذا الحسم بنسب ضئيله
بالنسبه للبرلمان لن يكون هناك اغلبيه
مريحه لكن بالنسبه للبرلمان حدث العكس
تحالف الشعب او الجمهور الذي
يتزعمه رجب طيب اردوغان تمكن من الحصول
على اغلبيه مريحه بينما في الرئاسيات
وجدنا انه هناك احتمال كبير للجوء لجوله
ثانيه وهنا سؤال دكتور باسل ليس نفس
الاشخاص الذين صوتوا في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه لصالح تحالف اردوغان هم لابسه
الاشخاص الذين صوتوا لاختيار الرئيس لماذا
اختاروا البرلمان باغلبيه مريحه لهذا
التحالف ولك عندما وصل الامر الى انتخابات
الرئاسه اختلف هذا الموضوع
مفارقه يعني على سبيل المثال اسطنبول في
الرئاسيات صوتت بالفارق اكثر من اثنين
بالمئه لصالح
المرشح مرشح تحالف الامه كمال كالجدار
اوغلو بينما في البرلمان التصويت كان
لصالح تحالف حزب تحالف الشعب او تحالف
الامه الذي يضم حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم مع
ذلك علاقه باختيار مثلا كليتشدار اوغلو
لعمده
اسطنبول او عمله لكي يكون شريكه في
الانتخابات او وعده بمنصف حال وقف وقوفي
الى الجانب في هذا الانتخابات
لم يحدث في اسطنبول
وحدث في مرات سابقه على سبيل المثال في
شرق تركيا في ديار بكر بالنسبه للبرلمان
معظم الاصوات
ذهبت لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي لكن في
الرئاسيه صوتوا لكم
هذا يرتبط في الدرجه الاولى
بعامل الايديولوجيا وايضا
يعني عوامل اخرى مرتبطه يعني البعض يرى ان
المرشح الرئاسي
يمكنهم اعطاء صوته صوتهم لهم لكن بالنسبه
لتوزيع الاحزاب يذهبون اذا لم يكن لديهم
حزب ينتمون اليه يذهبون للاقرب اليهم من
الناحيه الهوياتيه او الايديولوجيا هذه هي
العوامل التي
تؤثر في طريقه اعطاء الصوت سواء في
الرئاسيات او في البرلمان لذلك وجدنا هذه
المفارقه
التي تتكرر في او تكررت في انتخابات سابقه
ايضا طيب بالاضافه لهذه المفارقه التي
اشرت اليها يا دكتور باسل هل الوقت كافي
او ما تبقى من اصوات هل هو كافي لضمان فوز
احد
المرشحين ونحن نتحدث مثلا عن المراجعه
الاقرب هنا الراس طيب رجب طيب اردوغان
مع ان النسبه هي نصف بالمئه لكن يبدو ان
هناك صعوبه
بالحسم وتجاوز نسبه الخمسين بالمئه لو صوت
واحد يعني اعتقد بقي اثنين بالمئه من
الاصوات لم تفرز بالاضافه لاصوات الخارج
اصوات الاتراك في الخارج يعني هناك صعوبه
لاحتمال الاكبر اننا نتجه لجوله ثانيه
وهذا طبعا يعكس ربما رسائل اراد الناقب
التركي ايصالها الرساله الاولى بانه لم
يقتنع
في من خطاب المعارضه نحن الان نتحدث عن
معارضه واحده تضم سته احزاب بشكل معلن
احزاب الطاوله السداسيه
وحزب اخر صوت لهم حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
المفترض ان تتجاوز مرشحهم وبشكل مريح نسبه
الخمسين بالمئه الرساله الاخرى هي اعطاء
فرصه يبدو ان الناخب التركي يعطي فرصه
اخرى
لرجب طيب اردوغان لحزبه على الرغم من
استمرارهم في الحكم مده تتجاوز العشرين
عام ومعروف طبعا اي شخص عندما يقضي فتره
طويله في السلطه يظهر التململ لكن ما
لاحظناه من ارقام اليوم ان رجب طيب
اردوغان ما يزال رقما صعب في هذه المعادله
على الرقم من وجود عوامل اقتصاديه
تؤثر سلبا على
حظوظه تراجع في او تراجع نعم في سعر
الليره ارتفاع في التضخم ارتفاع في
الاسعار تداعيات زلزال كارثي الا ربما كان
لها تاثيرات كبيره والدليل على ذلك هذه
نتيجه المتقاربه
كمال كلتشتار اوغلو ولكن يبقى هناك سؤال
مهم الاصوات التي ضاعت ما بين الطرفين
ستذهب لمن اذا تم توجه الى جوله اعاده
دكتور باسل
هناك ايضا العديد من العوامل العوامل
الاول مرتبط بالمرشح الثالث
سنان اوران الذي حصل على نسبه خمسه بالمئه
وهي كانت نتيجه مفاجئه هو قبل عده ايام
تحدث وبشكل علني انه اذا
ذهبت الانتخابات الى جوله ثانيه فهو جاهز
للاتفاق او عقد صفقه مع اي طرف بحيث يضمن
سواء منصب وزاري او نائب للرئيس اليوم كان
له تصريح قبل عده ساعات عندما بدات
النتائج يعني او نقترب من الاعلان النهائي
لفرز الاصوات بانه لن يطلب من ناخذه
التصويت لكمال كالجار طالما انه يتحالف مع
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
ذو الجذور
الكرديه فمعروف هذا المرشح انه من جذور او
خلفيه قوميه
ايضا هناك عامل يتعلق
ربما
بطريقه التي ستدار بها
حمله المرشحين في الاسبوعين القادمين
وايضا خيبه امل
المعارضه او التحالف السداسي او السباعي
كيف ستنعكس هل سيستمر هذا التحالف خصوصا
انه ايضا في البرلمان لم يحقق اغلبيه
السؤال الكبير كيف سينفذ وعوده الانتخابيه
وخصوصا الوعد الاساسي او المحور الذي
اجتمع حوله كل هذه الاطراف تغيير النظام
السياسي العوده للنظام البرلماني اذا كان
لا يمتلك اغلبيه في البرلمان وموضوع
الرئاسه بات ايضا بالنسبه
لمصير كمالك الجدار اوغلو عليه الكثير من
علامات الاستفهام
باعتبار ان هناك عوامل انا سبق النتائج
لننتظر ونرى بعد ظهور نتائج
النهائيه لهذه الانتخابات يبقى معي دكتور
باسل اتحول ايضا بالتغطيه الى باريس مع
المحلل السياسي اسامه حريري سيد اسامه
اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه بالتاكيد
انتخابات من هذا النوع تعتمد بشكل كبير
على الاداء الذي كان لاي مرشح او الوعود
التي عدو بها المرشح
لناخبيه في الداخل ولكن هل كان للمواقف
الخارجيه لكلا المرشحين الرئيس اردوغان
والمرشح للرئاسه كليتشار اوغلو فيما يتعلق
بمواقف ربما اثرت بشكل كبير على الداخل
التركي تحالفات غربيه وشرقيه
نعم مرحبا صباح الخير يعني طبعا
شاسع جدا بين السياسه الخارجيه التي يروج
لها رجب طيب اردوغان والسياسه الخارجيه
التي في برمجه روج لها كريستار اوغلو يجب
علينا يعني ان ننتبه الى مساله معينه
اردوغان خلال السنوات الاخيره اتبع سياسه
نوعا ما صارمه او سياسه عدائيه اتجاهها
الغرب اتجاه حتى حلف الناتو التي هي تركيا
جزء اساسي منه وهي يعني ثاني اكبر جيش في
حلف الناتو على عكس الاشجار اوغلو الذي
يروج اكثر لسياسه اكثر انفتاحا على اوروبا
اكثر انفتاحا على مساء تهم الاتحاد
الاوروبي مثلا مثل
مسائل الحريات مسائل اطلاق سراح سجناء
طيب اردوغان تركيا اليوم اصبحت يعني
السجنة الكبير للعديد من الصحفيين
والمعارضين والاقليات وعلى راسهم الاكراد
بالتالي
المجتمع الكردي يلعب هذه الورقه لذا
الاقليات لدى الاكراد لذا ايضا الحركات
النسويه ومن خلال هذا الخطاب تقرر ايضا من
الاوروبيين من ناحيه مناشدته بهذه او
مطالبته باعاده هذه المبادئ ومنها ايضا
العلمانيه القويه الى تركيا من جهه ثانيه
رجل طيب اردوغان لعب ايضا على الوتر
الديني نوعا ما على وتر الصراع الحضارات
بين المعسكر الغربي وبين تركيا التي تريد
الحفاظ على هويتها والتي هي جزء ايضا طبعا
من القاره الاوروبيه ولكن لها هويتها
الخاصه ولها
خصوصيتها الخاصه
طبعا ببعض المسائل المتعلقه ربما
بالاستقرار داخل البلاد اردوغان لعب مساله
انه هو يعني التكمله
حكمه اعطى كثير من الاستقرار لتركيا نحن
نعرف جيدا تركيا عاشت خلال السبعينات
والثمانينات فقط حقبه كبيره من الانقلابات
العسكريه ربما نجح نوعا ما اردوغان في جلب
الاستقرار الى تركيا بالتالي هو لعب ايضا
هذه الورقه روج لها وقال يحاول طمانه
الشعب التركي والقول ان ان الرجل طيب
اردوغان هو الرئيس القوي الذي استطاع ان
يعيد الاستقرار الى الى تركيا هو الرئيس
القوي الذي يضرب بيده الحديد الجماعات
الكرديه المسلحه الذي يضرب بيد من حديد
ايضا عندما يحتاج امن تركيا يتدخل في
سوريا من ناحيه الثانيه يقول العكس يقول
ان ما قام به اردوغان ربما من تدخل في
سوريا او من تدخلات اخرى في ليبيا ومناطق
اخرى على العكس يزعزع الاستقرار في في
تركيا ويبعد ايضا يوما بعد يوم تركيا
الاوروبيين وهو ايضا اكثر يتوجه
يتوجه غربا قائلا ان مصلحه التركيه
النهائيه هي اكثر مع هذا الغرب اكثر محل
حلف الناتو طيب ايضا انقل الحديث الى
القاهره مع سيد ايمن فاروق الصحفي المعتص
في شان التركي بجريده الاهرام المصريه سيد
ايمن اهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه في الفتره
الاخيره قبل اشهر من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لوحظ تحول كبير في الموقف التركي فيما
يتعلق بازمات الشرق الاوسط كان هناك
نزاعات الطرف التركي كان له دور كبير فيها
فيما يتعلق مثلا بمصر بليبيا بالخليج وفي
سوريا وايضا العراق
التقارب العربي التركي الذي شوهد مؤخرا هل
كان له تاثير ماء على نتائج هذه
الانتخابات حتى الان
اهلا بحضرتك وباستاد الضيوف والساده
المشاهدين طبعا التغير اللي حصل في الاونه
الاخيره مع الملف العربي خاصه في مصر ودول
الخليج كان مقصود من السيد رجب طيب
اردوغان في اصلاح الشان التركي العربي لان
ده كان مقلق للعديد من الجاليات التركيه
الموجوده في الدول العربيه وايضا للعديد
من الناخبين اللي موجودين في تركيا في
فكره العداء الموجود دلوقتي مع الدول
العربيه اللي موجوده وخاصه الدول
الاسلاميه
وما يروج له الرئيس رجب طيب الدغام ان هو
الزعيم القادم للتحالف العربي الاسلامي
طبعا ده كان مقلق بشكل كبير جدا في وسط
التوترات ايضا اللي موجوده ما بين تركيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي وكان
تركيا تتقارب فقط من الدب الروسي بشكل
كبير جدا وده كان مقلق نوعا ما وكان
اثار عمل جيد جدا ومناخ طيب للمعارضه
التركيه في انها
ترى الوضع الراهن في تركيا بالخطر وتهدد
وتقول ان السياسه التي ينتهجها الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان في التفرقه وعزل تركيا عن
الوطن العربي وعزل تركيا عن الدول
الاوروبيه كان بمثابه خطر كبير في ظل
التطورات
والتدهور اقتصادي كبير شهادته في الفتره
الاخيره بعض الازمات العالميه اللي شهدتها
دول العالم مثل كورونا وغيرها والحرب
الاخيره الروسيه الاوكرانيه وجد ايضا
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ضروره التقارب
فيما يخص الدول العربيه
واصلاح هذا الملف بشكل جيد خاصه ان
العدائيه التي قام بها والتدخل السافر في
بعض شؤون الدول وما حدث تحديدا بشان دعم
حركات معارضه للنظام الحاكم والدعم ايضا
كل ما هو ينقض ويمزق في الشان الداخلي
المصري كان خطر داهم وده كان لازم لابد من
الافاقه منه
وتجنبه في الفتره التي يتجاوز فيها
بعض الحدود للجوده الانتخابيه التي نحن
بصددها الان طيب دعونا فقط نذكر بعدد من
الارقام والنتائج التي ترد تباعا عبر
وكاله الاناضول وهي نتائج بالطبع غير
نهائيه حتى الان تلك النتائج تشير الى انه
بعد فرج
98.67% من الاصوات ما زال الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان متقدما بنسبه
49.35% مقابل كلتشدار اوغلو الذي ما زال
محافظه عن رقم السابق وهو خمسه واربعين
بالبيع والارقام في الانتخابات البرلمانيه
متقاربه الى حد كبير من هذه النسب التي
اشرنا اليها عود الى باريس مع المحلل
السياسي اسامه حريري هذه المواقف التي
صدرت من المرشحين هل من المتوقع ان تتغير
بعد فوز احدهما ولنتحدث مثلا عن رئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان هل ستتغير مواقف الرئيس
اردوغان في حال فوزه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه
مواقفها الدوليه صحيح مواقف الدولي
لا لا اعتقد صراحه
بدا
حكمه خاصه بعد ان عزز السلطاته وطلبه
النظام بالنظام برلماني الى نظام رئاسي
لديه نوعا ما استراتيجيه واضحه لديه
تحالفات واضحه ولا اعتقد شخصيا انه سيغير
في السنوات القادمه بل على العكس سيستكمل
بسياسته هذه السياسه التي تعتمد على
مبداغماتيه كبيره جدا هو من ناحيه جزء
اساسي من حلف شمال الاطلسي من ناحيه ثانيه
يشتري انظمه دفاع جوي من روسيا هو من
ناحيه يعطي اوكرانيا
يحاول ان
يتفاوض او ان يسهل عمليه التمرير السفن
الحبوب بالتواصل الدائم مع روسيا وبلقاء
او بالاتصال المباشر دائما مع فلاديمير
بوتين من ناحيه يدعم مثلا في ليبيا طبعا
يعني بحسب كل المراقبين يدعم حكومه معينه
او طرف معين في ليبيا في المقابل تقوم
مثلا فرنسا والتي هي ايضا جزء من حلف
الناتو بدعم طرف اخر
السياسه التي يتبعها والتي بناها اردوغان
على مدى الاعوام الماضيه من يعني من الصعب
جدا ان يتخلى عنها لانها هو من وجهه نظره
يعني
انجز الكثير طبعا لبلده طبعا وجهه نظر
اردوغان بما
يطعم مسائل بالمساله الكرديه هو ماضن كل
المؤشرات تبين على انه ماضن في سياسته
الصارمه اما بما يتعلق يعني بالتقارب الذي
بدا مؤخرا بين بين تركيا والنظام السوري
هذا التطالب سيستمر على كل حال اصلا هذا
التقارب على ما يبدو نوعا ما موضوع جماع
حتى المرشح
وجهات نظره متقاربه من حيث الضروره
التقارب مع نظام السوري لاعاده
اللاجئين او عدد كبير من اللاجئين
السوريين من ناحيه ثانيه بخصوص المواقف
التي يدلي بها من فتره لاخرى والتي مثلا
ذهب احيانا فيها بعيدا الى اتهام مثلا
فرنسا بانها معاديه للاسلام او بان مكرونه
مثلا يقوم بالترويج لافكار مثلا معاديه
للاسلام كل هذا الخطاب نوعا ما الذي يحمل
نوعا من الشعبويه واللعب على العواطف
اعتقد ان هذه جزء اساسي من سياسه اردوغان
وسيتابع سيت فيه اللعب على هذا الوتر
احيانا الوتر الديني او الوتر مساله صراع
الحضارات طيب بيضا الموقف العربي سيد ايمن
فاروق هل تتوقع ان تتغير هذا التقارب من
العالم العربي في حال فوز رئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان برئاسه ام ان هناك مواقف اكثر
تقاربا صدرت من
اعتقد ان الرئيس تايب راغب طيب اردوغان
عند فوزه سيهتم اكثر بالملف العربي وسيتم
اصلاح هذا الشهر العربي بشكل كبير
خاصه ان الاتجاه للسيد كمال اوغلو هو
اتجاه علماني وممكن ان يؤدي الى صوره
جديده لتركيا غير تركيا الاسلاميه التي
يضعها الان
السيد رجب طيب اردوغان على دائره الدول
الاسلاميه وانه يتصدر المشهد الاسلامي
ويعمل بشكل كبير جدا على جذب تاييد الشعوب
العربيه الاسلاميه له بشكل كبير في قيادته
لتركيا اعتقد ان هذا الملف سيبقى قوي
وسيتم التواصل بشكل جيد خاصه انه تعهد انه
لن يعيد مره اخرى التدخلات التي كانت
موجوده في الفتره الاخيره وان تعرضه كان
مجرد خلافات مع بعض الانظمه السياسيه اللي
موجوده في الدول
وله شان هام جدا في علاقات الدوليه والملف
الخاص بالدول الاتحاد الاوروبي قد يشغله
اكثر من الدول العربيه والملف الروسي
الاوكراني ايضا طيب نتوقف مع حديث عن
الانتخابات التركيه للعام 2023 التي تعد
فاصله في الحياه السياسيه التركيه
والبصارى الذي ستتخذه البلاد في حال فوز
او خساره اردوغان
الانتخابات التركيه في 2023 انتخابات
مختلفه سياسيا واقتصاديا واجتماعيا هي
المره الاولى التي يواجه فيها اردوغان
تحالفا يضم سته احزاب معارضه بينها حزباني
كبيران كما انها ليست منافسه تقليديه بين
ائتلافين حاكم ومعارض بقدر ما هي صراع على
تحديد هويه تركيا في قرنها الثاني ومفترق
طريق ستسلكه البلاد باردوغان او بدونه
سواء كانت الانتخابات الرئاسيه او
البرلمانيه الثامنه والعشرين تحظى باهميه
واحده حيث تاتي بعد مرور 100 عام على
تاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
الطريق الذي ستنتهي به هذه الانتخابات في
حال فاز فيها اردوغان هو طريق قرن جديد
بوعود كبيره من قبل الرئيس التركي وفرصه
لتثبيت مشروعه السياسي اما خساره اردوغان
للرئاسه فقد تعني حقبه جديده داخليا
دستورا واصلاحات جديده وما تساله المعارضه
من خلال الاطاحه باردوغان بهدف دخول حقبه
جديده تبدا بالتراجع عن سياساته
داخليا اي منعطف تسلكه الانتخابات قد يعني
تغيرات توجهات تركيا الخارجيه خاصه الدوره
والتاثير التركيه في الشؤون الدوليه يمثل
تحديا للمعارضه فهو شهاده على انجازات
اردوغان عقدان كانت الفتره الاخيره الاصعب
فيهما فقد شهدت فيها تركيا متغيرات عده
اقتصاديه على راسها التضخم وكذلك كوارث
طبيعيه زلزال كان بمثابه اختبار للرئيس
التركي لذا فانما ستقرره صناديق الاقتراع
لن يتعلق فقط بمن سيحكم لكن بكيفيه الحكم
والمسار الاقتصادي الذي سيسلكه الفائز
وسياساته داخليا او خارجيا
[موسيقى]
نهايه السبعينات انضم الى حزب الخلاص
الوطني بقياده نجم الدين اربكان
عام
1983 عاد للصحه السياسيه كقيادي في حزب
الرفاه
عام
1994 انتخب رئيسا لبلديه اسطنبول
1997 اضطر الى الاستقاله
عام
1998 ادين بتهمه التحريض على الكراهيه
الدينيه اقصي عن الحياه السياسيه
يوليو 2001 انجازت له المحكمه الدستوريه
العوده للسياسه
اغسطس 2001 اسس حزب العداله والتنميه الذي
يتراسها
عام 2002 فاز حزبه بالانتخابات التشريعيه
من 2003 حتى 2014 تسلم منصب رئيس الوزراء
اغسطس 2014 فاز بانتخابات الرئاسه كاول
رئيس منتخب مباشره
زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 1992 عمل في
مؤسسه الضمان الاجتماعي من
1997 حتى
1999 تولى اداره مؤسسه الضمان الاجتماعي
عام 2002 بدا نشاطه السياسي في حزب الشعب
الجمهوري
انتخابات البرلمان التركي نوفمبر 2002 ثم
في اغسطس 2007 فاز بعضويه البرلمان في
الدائره الثانيه في اسطنبول
2009 ترشح لرئاسه بلديه اسطنبول الكبرى
خسر المنصب لصالح مرشح حزب العداله
والتنميه قدير توباش
2010 انتخب رئيسا لحزب الشعبي الجمهوري
بعد استقاله سلفه دينيز بايكال
مره اخرى الى انقره مع الدكتور باسل الحاج
جاسم دكتور باسل اذا الانتخابات
البرلمانيه ايضا تسير الى صالح تحالف
الرئيس اردوغان النسب تشير الى
49.31% وهي مقاربه بالنسبه التي حصل عليها
الرئيس اردوغان في صناديق الاقتراع
49.35 على عكس مثلا
الذي هو فاز بخمسه واربعين بالمئه من
الاصوات ولكن
التحالف الذي يقوده فاز فقط ب
35.19 وفي نسبه فرز قريبه من النسب
الرئاسيه نفس النسبه طبعا بالتاكيد لنا
عمليه الفرز التجري التزامنيا وفي نفس
الاوراق اوراق التصويت نتحدث عن
98.72% تحديدا من عمليات
الفرز السؤال الاهم في هذه
المرحله ماذا يعني مثلا لو حصلت المفاجاه
وف از كلتش دار اوغلو ولكن تقدم مثلا
تحالف اردوغان في الانتخابات البرلمانيه
سيكون هناك يعني
تضارب في السلطات او اشبه
بشلل سياسي صحيح ان الوضع اليوم هو نظام
رئاسي والرئيس يمتلك الكثير من الصلاحيات
الا ان وجود اغلبيه برلمانيه مريحه تستطيع
تعطيل الكثير من الاجراءات تستطيع
الدعوه لانتخابات مبكره تستطيع عرقله
الكثير من الخطوات التي يريد الرئيس
التحرك بها
وهنا يعني عندما كانت تطرح السيناريوهات
المتوقعه كان ايضا يتوقع ان يكون احد
المرشحين
يحصل على الفوز بالرئاسه بينما
التكتل الاخر يفوز
بالبرلمان
يعني كان يستبعد
الكثير من المراقبين او يقللون من
احتماليه هذا
السيناريو
بسبب يعني انه لا يمكن ان تحدث مثل هذه
المفارقه في توزع الاصوات لكن حتى الان
يبدو اننا نسير باتجاه هذا السيناريو
صحيح انه من المبكر الحديث عن نتائج
نهائيه الا ان عوامل كثيره
تلعب دور في تحديد الفائز
في الجوله الثانيه اذا ما اتجهنا اليها في
الرئاسيات من بينها ان التكتل الذي حصل
على اغلبيه في البرلمان قد يدفع الكثير من
الناخبين لتغيير تصويطهم في الجوله
التاليه
والتصويت للتكتل او مرشح التكتل الذي حصل
على اغلبيه في البرلمان لعدم الدخول في
هذا التعقيد في العلاقه او تضارب
جميل الى انتخاب الممثله والرئيس الذي
يمثل الكتله الاكبر ولكن ما الذي حصل كان
هناك حديث عن تقدم مرشح المعارضه كليتشار
اوغلو في لسبيانات
الاوليه ولكن هذا لم يعكس على صناديق
الاقتراع هناك حديث بان فوز الرئيس
اردوغان سيكون صعبا لان هناك ازمه
اقتصاديه تضخم زلازل والكوارث التي حصلت
في انقره والفتره الطويله التي قضاها
الرئيس اردوغان في الحكم في وقت قد يميل
بعض الاشخاص الى التغيير ما الذي جعل
اردوغان يتقدم بهذه النتيجه
صحيح يعني الكثير او معظم استطلاعات الراي
كانت تعطي افضليه لكم
لكن جرت العاده انه لا يؤخذ كثيرا
باستطلاعات الراي في تركيا من ناحيه ان
معظمها مسيس ومن ناحيه اخرى يبدو ان
المعارضه رفعت السقف كثيرا والخطاب
الاعلامي كان مرتفع جدا
ايضا
قد تكون الايام الاخيره للحملات
الانتخابيه
لعبت دور اساسي في ترجيح كفه اردوغان
باعتبار انه يتمتع بخبره طويله وجود
الكاريزما لديه
يعني طريقه ادارته
للحملات الشعبيه
وخطاباته
وايضا قد يكون الخطاب خطاب المعارضه لم
يقنع الناخب التركي لاننا كنا امام خطابين
او توجهين خطاب يتحدث عن الاستمرار
والاستقرار يمثله رجب طيب اردوغان والخطاب
الاخر التغيير والتغيير هنا نحو المجهول
في ظل ظروف اقتصاديه صعبه في ظل ظروف
ومتغيرات دوليه واقليميه كل هذه العوامل
قد تكون اثرت على التصويت وهو جعلتنا نرى
هذه النتائج لا اقول متقاربه هناك يعني
اكثر من مليونين ونصف مليون صوت لكنها
جعلت عدم قدره اي من المرشحين على حسم
الانتخابات الرئاسيه من الجوله الاولى الا
انه هنا لا يمكن اقفال حقيقه على الرغم من
وجود الازمه الاقتصاديه وموضوع تراجع
العمله
ونسب مرتفعه للتضخم للتضخم الا ان اردوغان
ما زال يحتفظ
بشعبيه اذا ما اخذنا اخر نتيجه
انتخابات رئاسيه هو فاز بفارق صوت اثنين
بالمئه فوق الخمسين يعني
مره اخرى هل اصبحت جوله الاعاده بحكم
الامر المؤكد نتحدث فقط عن ما يقارب ربما
65% من الاصوات فاصله 65% من الاصوات التي
يحتاجها اردوغان بالاضافه الى واحد للفوز
من الجوله الاولى هل الجوله الاعاده اصبحت
مؤكده ام ان هذا الكلام سابق لاوانه
انتظار الفرز النهائي لكل الاصوات ليكون
الحديث مؤكد ونهائي باعتبار ان المفاجات
دوما متوقعه الدكتور باسل الحاج جاسم
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
نتابع الحديث من باريس مع المحلل السياسي
اسامه حريري لا يمكن اغفال المواقف
التركيه اللافته فيما يتعلق بعدد من
الازمات الخارجيه تحدثنا عن ربما ماسك
العصا من النصف ما يتعلق مثلا بالازمه في
اوكرانيا ولكن لا يمكن اغفال تقارب التركي
الروسي مثلا على حساب
الموقف
التركي الامريكي هل هذا الموقف سيستمر ام
انه سيتغير بمجرد موافقه الولايات المتحده
مثلا على منح انقره صواريخ باتريوت او
طائرات اف 16 مثلا
يعني اردوغان مراوغ مراوغ ومفاوض
يعني محنك جدا صراحه هو بالنهايه يعني ليس
لديه ليس ليس هناك وراء كل ما يقوم به
ايديولوجيا معينه بل هو بامتياز بمعنى انه
عندما يقوم كما قلتم يعني المسك العصا في
النص عندما يقوم بالتعامل في نفس الوقت او
المغازله روسيا في بعض النواحي او شراء
منظومات دفاعيه جويه ليس حبا بروسيا وليس
يعني اعتقادا منه ان مصلحه تركيا العليا
هي مع روسيا بل بالاحرى للتفاوض في مرحله
ما على مسائل عده لممارسه مزيد من الضغوط
مزيد من الضغوط شاهدنا ذلك ايضا في مثلا
مساله ملف انضمام اسود وفنلندا الى الناتو
حتى الان من يعرقل فعليه الانضمام السويد
الى الناتو هي تركيا تطالب بثمن لقاء ذلك
خطابه مطالب بثمن ضمنه طبعا مساله ان تقوم
السويد بحذر نشاطات او بحتى ترحيل بعض
الناشطين الاكراد عدا عن اسمان اخرى ايضا
للضغط على الولايات المتحده لكي تقوم
الولايات المتحده ببيع مزيد من الاسلحه في
تركيا وبدعمها اكثر يقوم ايضا استخدام
اوراق عده للضغط مثلا مساله اللاجئين
راينا ذلك خاصه خلال يعني في عز ازمه
اللاجئين عندما بدا اللاجئين السوريين كيف
استخدم هذه الورقه ضد الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهدد بفتح الحدود وهدد بارساله هؤلاء
اللاجئين باعداد كبيره جدا الى اوروبا
بالتالي نعم يعني اردوغان في حال حصل على
الثمن الذي يريده من الولايات المتحده او
من الاتحاد الاوروبي
بشان يعني قضايا عده وذكرناها ومنها قضيه
المهاجرين او قضيه العلاقه مع روسيا كل
هذا الشيء نعم من الممكن ان يقوم اردوغان
بتغيير سياسته نوعا ما ولكن طبعا هذه
السياسه تبقى مرنه جدا لن يغيرها في ليله
وضحاها الا عندما يحصل فعليا على ما يريده
ولا اعتقد ان فعليا الولايات المتحده
ستكون مرنه في هذا الشان لن تقدم يعني شكا
على بياض لاردوغان بالتالي يعني سيواصل
اردوغان اعتقد من بشكل عام هذه سياسه
القائمه على المقايضه على القائمه على عدم
التمسك نوعا ما بتحالف الجيولوجي او
بتحالف دائم بل بالاحرى القيام تحالفات
صغيره تحالف من هنا تحالف تحالف من هناك
وحتى الان يعني هو استطاع بشكل جيد
الاستفاده نوعا ما من هذه الحرب من هجوم
الروسي على اوكرانيا من ناحيه ان انه عزز
نوعا ما دور التركي على الساحه الدوليه من
حيث ان التركيه اصبحت تلعب يعني نوعا ما
دور الوسيط تركيا اصبحت الراعي الرسمي
لمساله يعني
الحبوب او الحبوب الاوكرانيه لكي تمرر عبر
المضيق البوسفور عبر البحر الاسود الى الى
باقي الدول العالم بالتالي يعني
عزز موقف تركيا على الساحه الدوليه وهو
يرى ان هونه يقطف يعني ثمارا جيده من خلال
هذه السياسه
استفزازيه نوعا ما من خلال هذه السياسه
القائمه على المقايضه يخطف ثمارا قطف
ثمارا عديده من
على يعني على حساب اللاجئين السوريين
حصلت تركيا على مليارات
بالمئه في الانتخابات البرلمانيه مقابل
35.19
لتحالف كليتار اوغلو سيد ايمن فاروق
الايديولوجيه ليست الاهم الاهم هي المصالح
التي ستنعكس على الاقتصاد التركي وعلى
ما يريده الناخب التركي هذا ما قال الضيفي
من باريس ولكن هل ينسحب ذلك مثلا على
علاقه تركيا بجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
لاحظنا بان الخلاف الكبير فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقات العربيه التركيه مرتبطه بوجود
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بعد تراجع هذه
الجماعه بعد سقوط حكمها في مصر وتراجع
وجودها في المناطق عربيه متعدده هل مازال
الدعم التركي قائما لهذه الجماعه بشكل
مباشر وبالتالي عوده الخلاف متوقعه
مستقبلا ما بين تركيا والدول العربيه
طيب
اردوغان انتهت
يعني محليا في مصر ودوليا في معظم الدول
اللي هي موجوده فيها وما يتبقى من الاخوان
هو عمليات دلوقتي
فرديه بشكل ما لا توجد ايدولوجيه يا جماعه
الاخوان الدوليه لا يوجد وسائل الدعم
الكافيه
ايضا للنشاط جماعه الاخوان كان في الدول
العربيه لانه اصبح مكشوفا لدى الشعوب
العربيه ما هي جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وما
هي الاهداف التي تنتمي اليها جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين واساءه
او تشويه صوره الاسلام قبل جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين هو التصارع على الحكم وكان في
صله قويه جدا طبعا ودعم قوي من العلاقات
التركيه القطريه لهذه الجماعه واعتقد ان
الملف
التركي القطري بدا يتغير نحو الدول
العربيه في شكل داعم نوعا ما بشكل زي ما
احنا بنشوف في مصر دلوقتي اصبحت هناك
اختلافات في الملف المصري القطري واصبحت
هناك استثمارات قطريه وتعاون اقتصادي
وتعاون سياسي قوي بين مصر وقطر وايضا هذا
التعاون
سينصب مره اخرى الى العلاقات المصريه
التجاريه لان من مصلحه الرئيس طارق رجب
اردوغان في ظل هذه التحديات القاسيه التي
تعرض بها والظواهر الطبيعيه القاسيه
لتتعرض تعرضت لها تركيا في شهر فبراير
الماضي
ودمار الشامل
يعني طالع 11 ولايه تركيا ان العلاقات يجب
ان تكون
بعيدا عن الاعمال السياسيه بعيدا عن
التدخلات السياسيه في الدول العربيه هناك
تعاون قوي
وقد يكون ايجابيا ومساعدا للرئيس طارق رجب
اردوغان في الفترات القادمه الرئيس الثالث
عشر في تركيا محل انظار من جميع دول
العالم الان في ظل عدم دولي بشكل كبير جدا
في العلاقات التركيه العالميه التركيه
الروسيه والتركيه الامريكيه وتركيا
الاوروبيه والتركيه العربيه كل ده على
مائده واحده امام الرئيس طارق رجل اردوغان
اذا
اشارت الجوله الحاليه الى فوزه اما في قصه
المعارضه فاعتقد ان الاسبوعين ماضيين
القادمين هيشهد
ملفات سريعه جدا وتصرفات سريعه جدا سواء
من قبل الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان او المرشح
كمال اوغلو لتعديل السياسات لانها بالنسبه
للمعارضه هتكون مساله حياه او موت
لن تقوم قائمه مره اخرى المعارضه بعد
التحالف قوي واجراء انتخابات بهذه الظروف
وكل الظروف كانت يعني متاحه جدا لهم في
هذه المره وصناعه الديمقراطيه واج
لا يشربها اي شائب اذا هناك تكالب هيحصل
بشكل كبير جدا من المعارضه في الفتره
القادمه وايضا هيبقى في تعديل كبير جدا
واظهار للعديد من الملفات واهمهم من الملف
العربي التركي اللي حيسيره وهيبتدي يشتغل
عليه بشكل قوي لان لو قرانا في بعض
المشاهد وحللنا الانتخابات في الخارج هنجد
ان الرئيس طالب اردو راجل طيب اردوغان
نسبه التصويت له في الجاليات التركيه
الموجوده في الدول العربيه زي مصر
والسعوديه وقطر وسوريا هنلاقي فيها نسبه
ضعيفه او يعني بعض الشيء فلابد من تقويه
هذه النسبه بشكل قوي لتاييد الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان مع الجاليات الموجوده ايضا في
امريكا وروسيا والصين واكبر الجاليات اللي
ادت للرئيس اردوغان بحسبه كبيره كانت
موجوده في المانيا وفرنسا وايضا بعض الشيء
في انجلترا فلازم هنا حنشوف تدخل قوي من
حمله الرئيس الراجل الطيب اردوغان لاعاده
الملف التركي العربي ووضع اجنده قادمه
قد تكون بمثابه وعود له مع سواء الانظمه
العربيه او الشعوب العربيه سيتصاب حريري
اذا تحدثت عن مراوغه سياسيه تحدثت عن
مصالح تركيا اولا فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات
الخارجيه اللي انقره ولكن السؤال الاهم
الى متى ستتمكن انقره خاصه فيما يتعلق
مثلا اذا فاز بولايه رئاسيه جديده الى متى
ستستمر في مسك العصا من النص مستقبلا هل
نتوقع تقارب اكثر الى الولايات المتحده او
مع روسيا خاصه في ظل هذا الانقسام الشديد
بعد التدخل الروسي في اوكرانيا
صراحه يعني صعب نوعا ما التنبؤ
بالسياسه المقبله لرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
لكن رغم ذلك احبذ ان يستمر او يواصل
سياستها الخارجيه ولكن هناك نقطه مهمه يجب
اشاره اليها ان هيبه الرئيس اردوغان حاليا
في هذه الانتخابات كسرت نوعا ما هذا
الرئيس القوي الذي حكم تركيا احكم تركيا
منذ 20 عاما هذا الرئيس الذي
يمسك البلاد بقبضه من حديد اليوم يجدوا
يعني يجد نفسه مرشح عادي ايضا حتى لو كان
يعني في الصداره لم يكسب من الدوره الاولى
كل المؤشرات حتى الان الارقام التي نراها
امامنا تشير الى ان هناك علم يبدو بعد
اسبوعين من اليوم جوله ثانيه بالتالي ربما
هذه
هذا العامل اضافه الى عامل المشاكل
الاقتصاديه والتضخم الهائل جدا التي تعاني
منه تركيا بالاضافه الى عامل الزلزال الذي
اثر ايضا سلبا جدا على اقتصاد التركي وعلى
الراي الكثير من الناخبين الاكراد ربما كل
هذه العوامل قد تتبعه اكثر الى نوع من
العدائيه في سياسته الخارجيه للتغطيه على
مشاكل الداخل على المشاكل الاقتصاديه ربما
قد تدفعه اكثر الى نوع من
السياسه العدائيه خاصه تجاه الاكراد
وتحميلهم مسؤوليه
ماسي عده يعني تصيب تركيا ربما هذا الشيء
ايضا سيدفعه الى
ان يكون اكثر حتى برغماتيه ان يقوم
بالمستحيل لكي يحصل على ثمن معين ورب
ما هريدهم من الولايات المتحده ربما نعم
اردوغان هو مستعد للتضحيه
بنوعا ما تحالفها او بهذه العلاقه المميزه
جدا التي تربطه بروسيا في حال حصل على ثمن
رعايه جدا من الولايات المتحده ولكن هذا
الثمن الذي يعني الارجح يطلبه اردوغان
سيكون ثمنا هائلا جدا ومن الصعب جدا ان
تقوم الولايات المتحده الغاضبه جدا من
سياسه اردوغان باعطاء اردوغان ثمنا كهذا
نعم
الان نحن شرفنا على نهايه هذه التغطيه
ولكن بما ان النسب ما زالت متقاربه وهناك
اتجاه كبير الى جوله اعاده ثانيه برايك من
الرئيس المقبل لتركيا
يعني كل الرئيس صراحه المؤشرات الحاليه
طبعا تشير كما قلتم الى جوله ثانيه هذا
امر اصبح شبه نوعا ما مؤكد نسبه الى
الفوارق التي نراها يعني في الديناميه
الاخيره راينا التراجع عن طفيفا لرشا
اردوغان الذي كان فوق عتبه الخمسين بالمئه
الان اصبحت
49.35% صحيح مساله هناك اصوات تقريبا 30%
من الاصوات الذين صوتوا في الخارج
بالاضافه الى قرابه 1.3 ولكن هذه مجموعه
هذه نسبه الاصوات يعني حتى لو وصفت بنسبه
100 لصالح اردوغان سيكون من الصعب ان يصل
الى الى
ان يحصل ولكن الديناميه تلعب اكثر لصالح
اردوغان لانه يجيد هو اعتقد برايي هو من
ربما سيكون ارج بتركيا لانه يجيد لديه
كاريزما اكبر
مختلفه عندما يتعلق بالكاريزما الان
الحديث لكاريزما صناديق الاقتراع السيد
ايمن فاروق في عجاله من تتوقع الفائز في
الجوله الثانيه بالانتخابات اذا توجهنا
الى جوله ثانيه
في الجوله القادمه لانه صنع مشهد ديمقراطي
هو
هذه توقعات ضيوف من انقره وباريس نهايه
هذه التغطيه صباح العربيه على راس الساعه
شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات